[Applause]
Memphis it feel to be home it's great
it's hot it's always good to be home but
to be here and with all these wonderful
you know young hearts and minds they're
so creative and they are just soaking
this your we're at Stax Recording
Academy Stax Music Academy tell me what
you're doing here and and the
partnership with Levi's and how they've
contributed on the last tour on the man
of the woods tour we started
collaborating with Levi's on certain
pieces of clothing and we started this
kind of side brand with them called
fresh leaves and then we started talking
about what else could we do
their brand has always been really
implemented with with music and you know
the two are really synonymous so we were
talking about what could we do and you
know the first thing that came up was
Stax Music Academy and all the work that
these you know wonderful teachers do
down here with these you know really
beautifully creative kids and put
together this idea of what if I got you
know all my favorite collaborators or
some of my favorite collaborators yeah
we come down and we do basically a
workshop with these kids and we did it
yesterday and I mean it was honestly it
was one of the best experiences I've
ever had
[Music]
they take notes so quickly we just kind
of roamed around this is one of the
rooms we use we roamed around from room
to room because they're split off in
different groups and they were given
them an objective to write a song about
home so we all kind of came in we would
float around just there's five of us we
float around and and give notes and say
what if you tried this and I mean
honestly I was blown away at how good
the songs were already there was one
song that I heard and I just looked at
him I said I would cut this record if I
were you like this I don't really have
many notes where are you no kidding are
they intimidated or were they asking you
questions were they really reading with
you or just kind of I think they were
really excited to have all of us here
they were very excited when I think we
were a surprise
yeah they freaked out yeah yeah I guess
a little bit I was it's always nice to
kind of feel that energy but I think
once we got there was a couple of
moments where we're you know I would
give one of them a note and won it one
of the kids just meant and I was like
what you don't like egos nod I just I
just can't believe I'm sitting here
taking notes from you and but but then
would jump right back in and implement
it and it's okay so I guess a little bit
about yeah why is it important for you
to give back well I mean listen you know
I've been lucky enough to have this
platform and this privilege and what's
the best way that I can be involved in
integrating people you know humans and
music is that's the that's the universal
language you know you go overseas you
could be in you know Denmark and they
know every word to every song and I just
remember being younger and having that
happen and and thinking you know music
really is a thing that binds I think
it's just so important for people like
myself to use this privilege to M my
gifts to be involved in
community and music is the most fun way
to do it so that's why we're here it's
your main little guy Silas how old is he
now by the way who's four four yeah it
happens fast if he were to say dad I
want to be in the business I want to do
what you do absolutely there no no no no
I'm kidding I don't know I don't know
luckily he's four and I don't have to
think about that yet I'm still trying to
figure out how to like manage a four
year old son he's into the tractors and
the trains and all he said he's into
everything yeah he's into everything
yeah
so we're here at Stax Music Academy but
you've also been posting a lot from the
recording studio yourself so does that
mean new music on the way hopefully soon
hopefully you know you know to be honest
I'm in this finish the tour and my 38
year old body neither be needed most of
the summer to like recover from that
because you can't really explain what to
our life is like but it really overtakes
you even your whole system I just called
my publishers and I said you know I just
want to work with with young fresh
people and I want to collaborate more
and you know I've been song writing and
producing for so long I want to
experience that energy and I want to
work with people that I think are truly
you know amazing and Rizzo came by
worked with scissor the other day and
just worked with Meek Mill and I'm
having these experiences that are
fueling me in such a different way and
again I think it was really birthed out
of feeling like what can I do right now
to just be a part of my community and
and integrate
[Music]
checkmate baby how you feel
those are not met at the funny enough at
the Songwriters Hall of Fame and I was
like I'm such a fan if you ever want to
write and she was she I think she
thought I was lying but we got in and
and we got a couple of ideas I don't
know when they're gonna come out but
they're pretty good I'm not gonna tell
you too much about what we did together
in the studio if she wants to tell you
she can but it's bull Eames it is so
good I'm so excited about it talk about
the tour and what it takes out of you
last year you had to take vocal rest I
did how hard was that for you and how
scary I feel like I have to take vocal
rest like for a period of every day yeah
like yeah just be quiet
that's right but not this second no not
the second I know not this second
I think like I said I think it was just
a culmination of the same schedule with
a little bit of an older body and that's
the muscle that I'm using so much I
think mom I think I just needed a break
yeah and which is tough for me to
swallow because I'm like this keep going
you know my doctors were like yeah
stop yeah it makes me think about how
supportive Jessica must have been
through that time sure how has she
influenced you how has she changed you
in so many ways I think anybody out
there you know you go through anything
to have somebody by your side to really
go through with you and get in the mud
with you so to speak I'm sure you know
what that's why that little sparkles in
your eyes it's I'm standing next to this
one how can you know
[Music]
once you find that person that's like a
baptism where you're like I can't go
back you know what I mean like I don't I
can't go back so which is what
fatherhood's like - so I'm just enjoying
the ride I have something I think you're
gonna like you know I just want to still
be on Entertainment Tonight ten years
from now that'll be cool maybe I'll come
host a show what am I wearing now I know
you're in the press cuz you are lying
out of your teeth
no no no the oppor still stands
ET comme host anytime what do you come
host all right I don't know if I'm
equipped you know I don't speak well if
I wrote it down in a song up see I can
do look what's happening that I know
Lester don't show that clip to anybody
that they're an outfit that's just you
know I got to live out my awkward years
in front of all of you and it's it's
it's it's it's really it's haunting me
I'm not gonna lie I just you know okay
I'm getting practice right now so all
right back to this competition so where
are you in this stage with the kids so
what happened was yesterday we worked
with all of them and we kind of like you
know let them take the wheel back and
they're sort of like putting the
finishing touches on of their songs that
they worked on and now we're gonna go
here then we're gonna judge some of the
teachers reported back that like know
how hard it is to get them to stay after
and like keep working on their stuff cuz
they all want to go do that they're
teenagers you know they want to go live
life and he said they're after yesterday
he said they just stayed here like for
the longest time I worked on their stuff
that's so inspiring for me because you
you dream up something like this on a
wait in a way that you can give back and
then to see that it actually does make a
difference in their whole energy
you just never know what fire you might
you know you might like with one of
these young people or a group of them
and we could you know we could have the
next you know Beyonce or John Legend or
you know Adele in that room so a legend
not just a John Legend type a legend
our reporter on the scene is Tommy Jones
Tommy hi Tommy Jones here reporting to
you from the first floor hall where Miss
Hepplewhite is talking to unidentified
foreign exchange students via zoran hand
signals no Thomas Hepplewhite index
finger has been at a forty four degree
angle thirty years ago we first met you
with the Mickey Mouse Club
okay celebrated its 30th anniversary
that's right
so in separate interviews Christina and
Britney said they would be down for a
reunion would you ever be down sure it's
so cool being here and being a part of
being this much influence on a young
person who maybe feels different or like
they don't belong and they found music
as a thing that has brought them
together because I think that was
something that we all shared in common
was we were you know 10 and 11 even a
little bit younger than then these kids
are and we all felt like the weirdos in
our selective states and counties and
schools and so to have met all of those
people at that time and then to all come
together and be influenced and that was
the most influential experience I ever
had I mean we were 10 years old we got
to learn how to be on camera we got to
learn how to write dance saying acts we
would be in front of a live studio
audience and trying to do comedy and so
yeah I mean my my relationship with that
was like ultimate fields
see you real soon
[Music]
but because we like you
[Music]
[Applause]
tell me about this room and it's called
the song lab yeah this is what we're
doing in here this is this is what we
this is what we made yeah you know and
this is a song lab but this is not the
only one I mean this is this is specific
to these instruments and and but there's
other rooms too where they get to work
with things like you know this hooked up
to their their laptops and they can make
they can program music as well so we
want to really I want them to make live
music and sequence music and bring it
all together and make music that fuels
them we're here at Stax Music Academy
and it's important to remember how it
changed the world I also want these kids
to be able to make their music as well I
want them I want them to be able to
cover Aretha Franklin and Otis Redding
but I also want them to be able to
sample them and like turn it into
something else
this room is specific to instruments but
they have other rooms too where they're
all got their headphones on and they're
making beats well thank you
honestly I've learned so much in the
last 48 hours I feel like I'm like I'm
like fueled up and ready to get back in
the studio only on et and getting
practice right now so great
you